I talk about media skepticism and media
literacy and sort of learning to be
informed and critical consumers of media
messages all the time and sometimes it's
just genuinely difficult to figure out
whether what we're being told is coming
from an expert or a corporation or how
money might be influencing the messages
that we hear I'll tell you one story
which is absolutely horrifying back in
2015 Henry Miller who's a fellow at the
Hoover Institution
that's an institution at Stanford
University in California top
institutional top educational
institution in the country Miller wrote
an editorial in Forbes calm okay wrote
an editorial his name appears on it he
claims it as his own he's an expert
right we can trust what it says well
what did it say this editorial in 4.com
said that glyphosate had just been
classified as a probable cancer-causing
substance and that that's bad in other
words Miller disagreed with the
classification by the World Health
Organization of glyphosate as a possible
carcinogen Henry Miller wrote the piece
in Forbes attacked the decision said
it's a bad decision
we shouldn't be classifying glyphosate
as a carcinogen okay couple years go by
the Monsanto papers have now been
released and that includes emails
correspondence between Monsanto
agribusiness giant Monsanto and Henry
Miller and it turns out that Monsanto
actually wrote the entire piece that
Henry Miller put his name on and Henry
Miller added a few words to it before it
was published and the email chain is so
disgusting that it really makes your
skin crawl the emails show that Monsanto
went to Miller and they said hey would
you be willing to write about the
International Agency for research on
cancer saying that glyphosate is a
carcinogen and he wrote back saying I
would be if I could start from a
high-quality draft
I'm absolutely inundated with projects
right now what is he saying he is
hey Monsanto I'll say what you want me
to say as long as you're really writing
most of it because I'm really really
busy right now
now why would Monsanto care about
glyphosate well they have herbicides
that use glyphosate period right I mean
that . that's why Monsanto would care
about this and within a few days of that
exchange by email Monsanto sent Miller a
draft and the draft is available and you
would notice that the draft is almost
identical to what was eventually
published in Forbes under the name Henry
Miller Miller was contacted by CBS San
Francisco to comment on this didn't
respond in a statement provided by
Monsanto Scott Partridge who's the
company's vice president of global
strategy said quote that was a
collaborative effort a function of the
outrage we were hearing from many people
the infamous many people on the attacks
on glyphosate this is not a scientific
peer-reviewed journal it's an op edie we
collaborated with him on so it's true
it's not a scientific peer-reviewed
journal it's forbes.com but even still
it was never disclosed that it was a
collaborative effort it was published
under Henry Miller's name implicitly
based on his personal expertise in the
subject matter as a fellow of this
institution at Harvard so basically at
this point what do we need to do as
media consumers particularly of science
news even articles by scientists in
popular publications need to be looked
at very skeptically science writing
should be looked at in peer-reviewed
journals that is sort of the idea that
we should all have in our minds but the
problem is even articles written about
peer reviewed journal studies need to be
approached cautiously it is very common
that you'll read something in Forbes or
any online publication and it'll appear
legit because it cites a peer reviewed
journal PLoS ONE or the Journal of
biochemistry whatever so we assume oh
well it's based on good research that
was done many times the headline and
even the summary a
what a peer-reviewed study found is not
actually accurate it will not actually
appear in the peer-reviewed study if you
go and look at it and then the truth is
even if every single time you say you
know what I'm not gonna listen to what
Forbes says about the peer-reviewed
study I'm gonna pull up the
peer-reviewed study myself and look at
it there are also problems with
peer-reviewed science at this point you
can still look at peer-reviewed science
and come away believing things that are
inaccurate inaccurate there's a big
problem right now with bad science
slipping by even in peer-reviewed
journals we just told you about this we
hear about 97% of papers on climate
science say it's human caused three
percent say it isn't a study was done of
that three percent that says climate
said climate change is not human caused
there were major just fundamental
methodological flaws in that 3% so sadly
I wish I had better news for you what I
can suggest is critically animal
analyzed primary sources that's number
one I call that caps I'm actually giving
a speech in a couple of weeks at a
college about media literacy caps
critically analyze primary sources
number one and then try to get
corroborating sources as well because
sadly even within the world of
peer-reviewed journal science there are
things that are not good that are
getting in there back to our story
really smart scientists write believes
glyphosate isn't carcinogenic or is it
Monsanto believes glyphosate which they
have a financial interest in isn't
carcinogenic and they want to get some
scientists to sign off on it
vial absolutely vile stuff today's
program is made possible in part by
independent artist types from Grand
Rapids Michigan bringing you the new war
EP it's a multi shun repressive humanist
response to the ongoing culture war in
America here is a clip from the song the
side
[Music]
you can hear this song and many others
in their entirety at types VanCamp calm
that is types with forties types with
forties Bandcamp calm if nothing else
and of course there's much else Donald
Trump the Donald Trump era has inspired
a whole new era of protest and
politically themed music and you can
find exclusive demos and live recordings
on the type's patreon and YouTube pages
as well both of which are spelled with
four T's